okay this talk is about computer vision
I split it up in a couple of very simple
topics but require me very little time
to explain so mainly like all style
image classification field detection how
it used to be done how can be done now
as shadi mentioned some improvement on
phase analysis detection recognition
generic purpose object attack dose and
always useful semantic segmentation and
then my colleague Michael is gonna give
an example about how to build some
useful there's something useful out of
all of this in a specific case of text
detection in the world okay let's let's
start so you may have noticed that since
version 10 now we have a complete fully
automated yet customizable framework to
do image classification which is built
in within classify so what happens
typically done if you ever played with
this you can have data like this you can
say oh I have like a bunch of classes
bunch of images and I want to train a
classifier and you just put the data in
I just pick the method here because I
wanted to control what it was and and
then what I'm gonna do now is I'm just
an import them because we don't have
time this is like like five minutes but
I don't want waste this time and these
things here gives a classifier function
but you can use like any normal function
and that's it like this what you need to
do email classification with this very
very simple built-in framework another
very good feature but I hope everybody
is using but I'm always repeating that
in every tool because it's very nice is
that you can plug the function into a
measurement function that will pre
compute all sorts of measurements and
then you can query them like I'm doing
now to see what's going on basically
nice fullscreen thing okay there is more
I don't know if you can see that this
says for example that we got 84 percent
accuracy this is ten classes database
that I trained with only 300 images per
classes because my laptop is not that
powerful and it's already pretty good
with this amount
data and of course since a bit more
recent and then there some ten we we
support we have a fully functional
high-level very simple to use neural
network framework so I put this code
here that generates a simple
convolutional net I'm not gonna explain
this is the usual stuff if you have
questions you can come to me later
yeah please the images and if you wonder
like how do they become data the
built-in feature structure for images is
using a component to convert them to an
embedding space you can you can do
whatever you want you can specify the
feature structure I think the default
one is using something like this but you
have no control with this thing here you
can define your own network and you can
do whatever you want with this and what
I did yesterday is I took that Network
this code okay I was using the building
cypher 10 so I just need to put this
string in to do this testing training I
don't even need to copy data this would
be taken from cloud and I say but if you
set automatic because this research data
has some testing data built in and then
I say train on GPU which will not work
here but it was working on Amazon and
and I said the bar size because
something I wanted to Train very fast
and what happened basically if I import
this it happened this so this is again
very small but it says that in train in
five minutes and it's pretty fast
Network now so it is like 7000 example
per second on that GPU so it's way more
than real time there and again I can
import a classifier measurement and I
see that with this network that I put
together with Carlo while we were
drinking coffee yesterday we got from 80
to 89 percent accuracy of course if you
study this a bit and if you if you if
you work on your architecture and you do
proper documentation and whatever you
can do it more and right now this like
standard standard stuff for an image
classification so I'm gonna go very fast
with this this was all style feature
detector for neural networks what you
would do is maybe
histogram of oriented gradients plus
support vector machine was a kind of one
of a best performance thing the idea is
that you you know take the gradients of
these images you check the orientation
you do the histogram the face is gonna
have a different Instagram then a random
patch so then you can again compute some
features let's say I think you can show
them here and you set a training data
and then you run it to classify with the
support vector machine huh this is 3d
graphics which is doing everything okay
here these are the features of the
arranger gradients
I'm not going to turn it sorry sorry
okay and what's happening here basically
if I can scroll
I shouldn't have customized a built-in
stylesheet what happens here if you
train this is that you get this nice
classifier but I should probably retrain
here because I broke it with the other
one and this has to show how this works
basically language in in real time you
you look a bit that yeah also other
training data okay this is a note for
myself use different names for different
variables so this is how you train a
classifier in real time and this is
useful metric like this is a very short
training it's gonna be like 20 seconds
but this can go on for minutes hours
it's gonna tell you how it's going and
is even gonna try different methods
right now is support vector machine so
it's trying different parameters within
the same method and of course you can
clear it you can extract everything and
you can even force it to use specific
parameters and once this is done you can
you can try it on for example the crops
and say like right up this was very bad
training used to be 0.6 this morning so
this weather guys for not setting it but
you see that the probability of
something being being a face crop is
very different in this case than in this
case of course if you find you knit a
bit and this was like all style cascade
classifier
take an image you split it in multiple
parties and this is what you get when
you apply it so for example yeah
these are like my my random classifier
like was able to pick do a simple face
detection
old style of course you can even train a
network to do that and it's also much
faster and this is something I trained
with a colleague of mine that is doing
the same thing but is using neural
networks too instead of like doing
custom handcrafted priors is training
the features on data set itself if you
distract on procedure yeah this looks
relatively well to do all of that I mean
to do all of that and we need good
visual certain capabilities which in
turn they are also enhanced by the use
of proper neural networks so this is
what we could do before it's the right
thing I'm sorry for that but now we are
doing the green thing which is so much
better and and this is what you get with
enhanced capabilities in your network
for free detection because the old style
cascade was actually before like you
needed to really really focus on a tight
title defined problem neural networks
can learn a wide variety of features in
this case I can learn to detect faces in
any orientation for example and this is
also reasonably fast so like you see if
I turn it and I mean it kind of works
almost all the time now but what you do
once you had these these affections okay
one thing you can do for example is run
a bunch of networks so I recently
trained the H network is a little better
a little more honest even if you're not
sure that it's good thing then you can
get for example sex and emotion is
another like kind of standard play thing
to test these kind of things and another
thing you can do is of course landmarks
which is very useful for like you know
morphing alignment all these fancy phone
apps but you have are using something
like this or what color just showed for
audio you can do it for face as well
yeah you can you can embed each image in
custom descriptor and if you know what
I'm talking about you may know what
is going then using this script you can
do some sort of recognition so okay I
give you Boosh oh where is a bummer I
swear I had also bomber here I don't
know where it went
it's not a political statement so what
this thing is doing is is getting is
getting the the images for my example
features such it's looking at the embed
is comparing them in benning's place and
says okay
this person that you have here
corresponds in the feature space is very
close with this person here so I'm gonna
give the label Bush with these
probability which is very high and if I
remove one Bush image for example it is
high but not that much high like you
know I lose it a bit and of course like
with more images that you have if you
have like a photos up on the Mac like
the more images you add the better it is
in suggesting like oh is this you here
is this your daughter do you want to
search all the images with your mother I
don't know why but so I mean you can
build applications like this and and
then that's a free-form detection like
this was all tightly tailor to faces but
you can do stuff like this yeah same
image and this is what you get out and
okay these are people these are objects
and of course we have a lot of
convenience functions so you can
directly plug it in highlight image it
will compute it on the image and Bob you
show something like that and if you have
a decent network this might even work
real time so let me try I don't know if
this thing is going to work so this is a
video of a dog which is annoying this
low ok this dog is crossing the the
camera and what i'm doing here i'm using
another convenience function which is
called image containing skill that is
like does this image contains dog maybe
okay this is what happens on my laptop
which is not super real-time but you see
the image turns green when you have a
dog so you can use it i don't know like
is my baby stealing the camera huh maybe
yeah I hope so
and oh yeah I promise cut in a summary
don't know if you read that so you can
even detect cats of course because you
don't have cats on scene
processing applications and okay let me
let me end on a more serious tone here
what's the man discrimination and other
cool computer vision applications
basically you want to assign a meaning
to every pixel in the image why this is
important practical example is medical
imaging you you have a brain scan you
have something like you have tons of
these scans and you want the doctor to
only look at the important one or maybe
when you're not sure so it would be
great if you could filter them
pre-filter them with the network and
what this thing is doing for example if
I know this is nice called you net model
because it compresses and uncompressed
assuming it has nice you shape if you
visualize it and then I get an image and
then what happens if I evaluate this
mask these networks on the image it
creates a mask before which is not
related with a my show so this takes a
bit of time because it has to first it
down sample the image to you know
collect all the features and typically
you end there but now I want to also to
up sample to find out what the correct
mask is and if I visualize this together
so basically this is what a doctor could
could get you can see that yeah so the
idea is like are take a look here this
this cell might be problematic or like
oh this is regular thing
like I'm super sure let's let's keep it
for now so like this it just was a very
very quick overview of stuff that you
can do with our computer vision related
functions in the language and for more
practical applications I'll just leave
the floor to my colleague Miguel please
let's go talk about text detection thank
you
[Applause]
can you hear me okay great so all right
so Giulio explained like what do we have
instance of object detection so text
detection is a custom case for object
detection which is quite trendy now and
because we have like a lot of you know
like need to recognize the text but to
recognize it first we need to figure out
where it is and it can be problematic
because the tech skills can be like
skewed rapped warped and it's not very
trivial problem so okay alright so we
will be introducing some a new function
which is going probably going to be
called fine text and it will basically
allow you to extract almost all the
possible features you can describe the
text on your images which is basically
all possible variations of regions it
can be you know like oriented bounding
boxes which is basically parallelograms
or normal bounding boxes skewed angles
the strength of the recognition regions
and and oh I mean this is pretty much
enough to do so just just to see a few
examples how this thing looks we can see
for example like this is an example that
sorry also showed so basically we are
extracting the image and aligned image
with some descriptive properties of the
text that is located on the image and we
can do the same thing on various type of
images because we have basically scanned
images natural images we also have web
images so but if we try to classify them
into true groups we have only natural
images which kind of same includes web
images and we also have document type
images which is scanned images so this
is going to work on both of them as well
within the same quality so we can do the
same thing on different level which
gives us room to
drill down from Chora to to character
level and expand to right now this is
line but this is going to probably be
extended right so as usual and as the
other functions that are present in
Wolfram language we are going to provide
you with options that will will help you
to figure out you know like what will
you need for your very custom case for
example like I'm not going to list all
the options because like we have more
than a few dozens but may be the most
interesting and useful one so for
example ones acceptance threshold that
allows you basically to you know like
filter out the detection based on the
level of confidence let's name it this
way another another very useful thing is
metal actually the so the function is
going to be some very smart so you don't
really need to tell if this is you know
like scanned image or natural image
because we have an internal classifier
that does the job for you but if you are
like super sure you are smarter than the
classifier and you want to specify this
you are free to do it with the method
option just for now I want to show like
the detection results both on on a
raster image which is basically a
document type of image and on a natural
image and you can see I mean we we don't
have a very skewed text here but we
still have an angle presence of you know
like angle and it's still doing pretty
good job another maybe yeah the last but
not least important the option I want to
talk about is the padding so when
drilling down to the Turk level
especially and on the other levels as
well doesn't really matter based on the
application and the custom needs one may
need to adjust the padding and you know
like - I don't know I don't know for
what problem for segmentation for
example oh and actually you you will be
able to you know like now we're
expanding but you you will be able to go
down to the you know like up to the
point size so maybe if you need that for
your application right so I I don't
really want to talk about much about the
function because this is not designed
this is not well this is not ready yet
but let's let's see what we can
use it for so um oops okay so let me
show you something so we have an office
in Armenia and so this is basically our
door looks this is basically normal
you know like laminate door with with
sticker on it saying like warm research
and stuff so what we can do so first we
can basically detect the text and then
we said we're doing it on a level or own
levels so say character level world
level line level and using that
information we can construct a small
super function which will you know like
generate mask binary mask for for image
and allow us to segment the whole image
instead of segmenting you know like
characters words or lines so just to
give you an example what this can be
used for is that we can tweak the color
of the text on image leaving the rest of
the image untouched but this is very
very basic in toy example but this gives
you an idea of a very basic you know
like segmentation application using the
text detection functionality
another thing okay so another field that
that is that becomes yes of course
and another field that becomes reachable
let's name it this way is plate
recognition so you can see I mean like
it's not like super accurate because
this particular you know like networks
that we use now they are not exactly
designed for car plate recognition but
as long as this is this can be
interpreted as a natural image it does a
decent job not very very accurate but
not hundred-percent I could but still
very decent job I mean you can see
through few images that the car plate
recognition goes pretty well and
interestingly it doesn't really care if
you know like your car plate is a
standard car plate or has you know
multiple lines on stuff everything is
being recognized detect it and I mean
over here we have like recognition going
over which is basically giving us the
actual you know like car plate
identifier right so
another another interesting field of
application that can be utilized is
basically analyzing business cards
because I mean I personally have I don't
know like tons of business cards gathers
from through my whole life and if you
ask me like who is there and to where I
called them from I have zero clue but
what you can do actually is basically
using the okay you can use the you know
likes that the semantic interpretation
and intended functionality of finding
text to try to analyze your business
cards basically in this particular case
I'm just getting you know like who this
card belongs to and what is the location
associated to to the play to to the card
owner I mean it might be not present on
the card so for example you can see we
have some of them you know like without
any identification but if it is present
it will be identified right and okay so
I have four minutes left and the last
application and the most important one I
want to talk about is basically creating
a super function using using the
functionality of finding text so what we
are talking about so let's basically
first run through a very simple example
so we'll take an image so we basically
shoot a you know a short video and this
is a simple frame from from the video so
as I said I mean but for you to
understand so this is a company this is
the corner line between natural images
and intent scans documents so this is
kind of because we have natural image
and scan text in it so this is not a
trivial image so that's what I'm trying
to say so what we can do first we can
you know like get the data which is in
our case we're interested in you know
like line wise takes detection for and
we are getting the aligned images out of
it then we can use the functionality of
text recognized which is also being you
know like having a huge update in in the
next version and it's now very very
acumen way more accurate than it was
before
and
we recognize basically whatever is there
now we can basically try to you know
like put all this information on a frame
to imitate the effect of subtitle so we
create a sub theta because way which is
basically you know like taking the
strings and cuttin a ting them together
then we can use another functionality of
warm language is basically text
translation and use the services to
translate this German and alright so it
translated and now we can use the app
you know old-school rasterize and
rasterize this to get a graphics
eventually we can combine them and you
know like we will see how the over text
is you know like translated and
rasterize there so still not nothing you
know like not only to hard-code anything
everything automated next we can find
the face and since you know like this
guy didn't give you any permission to
show his face i have to close it so last
but not least we can use audio because
we talk about audio a lot and to it will
not be fair not to show that and we can
create a button and you push on it and
nothing happens oh yeah you have this
off no no we have to show these I spend
too much time preparing this okay no no
just take it out take it out
Oh nobody was to burn the built-in okay
headphone port yep
my name is fine text okay my name is
fine text no we cannot
so no no but really it's too early for
applause now right so we used some
subset of functions but we can extend it
I mean we can we used only only ten or
something which is nothing for a super
function so we can add more you know
like video capabilities audio
capabilities do anything out of core
maybe yeah and then and eventually so
what you so now just to make this point
clear again so there is no hard calling
everything is being synthesized
everything is automatical and you
basically can process to this whatever
we did on a frame on a video
[Music]
if Benny continued functionally
baden-baden 12 contain
I'm against fixed
it's been scuffle alright so everything
is synthesised here so nothing is hard
for it or anything else alright so yeah
so that's it
so thank you
[Applause]